it was long awaited but as expected
the cia believes that saudi arabia's
crown prince
mohammed bin salman did authorize the
killing of journalist jamal khashoggi
in a short four-page executive summary
the intelligence agency said that it
based its assessment on
the crown prince's control of
decision-making in the kingdom
the direct involvement of a key advisor
and members of mohammed bin salman's
protective detail in the operation
and the crown prince's support for using
violent measures
to silence dissidents abroad including
khashoggi what's your reaction to the
report
it's a historic moment this
uh and makes it quite clear that it
leads right to the top to the to the
crown prince
uh ordering and approving this uh
horrific
operation jamal khashoggi went to the
saudi consulate
in istanbul on october 2nd 2018
to pick up papers allowing him to wed
his turkish fiance
as she waited for him outside he was
ambushed
tortured and killed inside
initially saudi arabia denied any
knowledge of his disappearance
then finally admitted he had died in a
fight
mohammed bin salman said that he took
personal responsibility
but had no knowledge of the killing the
biden administration has announced
financial and visa sanctions with the
state department banning
76 saudis from entering america
but not mohammed bin salman i spoke
yesterday with the king
not the prince made it clear to him that
the rules are changing
and we're going to be announcing
significant changes today and on monday
we are going to hold them accountable
for human rights abuses
the saudi government has rejected the
report as
negative false and unacceptable
the relationship with with saudi arabia
is an important one
we have significant uh ongoing interests
we remain committed to
the defense uh of the kingdom
but we also want to make sure and this
is what the president has said from the
outset
that the relationship better reflects
our interests
and our values president biden
isn't taking any specific action against
mohammed bin salman
that will be controversial for some but
the white house is calculating
that the very release of this report
will be humiliation enough
for saudi arabia's young crown prince
alice bunker sky news washington